blue diamonds they are the rarest gems
in the world and are causing a frenzy
with buyers selling at record prices
this spring
Sotheby's will try to cash in on that
enthusiasm at their magnificent jewel
sale in New York the star of the show
the Shirley Temple blue diamond this is
Shirley nine point five four carats very
rare color fancy deep blue its BBS
clarity with the potential to actually
be internally flawless
back in 1940 the father of child acting
star Shirley Temple bought the ring for
seventy two hundred dollars
Sotheby's estimates it's now worth
thirty five million dollars and with the
celebrity of its former owner that
estimate may be low you don't know on a
given day
who will place a value on that
provenance and how much value they'll
place on it we really based the estimate
on the stone and then watch the
provenance take it from there with
Shirley Temple provenance you have no
idea where it's going to go
Sotheby's has a track record of selling
colored diamonds at blockbuster prices
it sold mrs. Paul melons blue diamond
pendant for a record 33 million dollars
in 2014 last fall it shattered that
record when Hong Kong billionaire Joseph
Lau paid over 48 million dollars for the
blue moon diamond I think because those
prices were earth-shattering that's why
the market is so good it went from 3
million in carat to 4 million a carat
and that's where the market is
Christie's is challenging set to be sale
this season in May it will put the
largest blue diamond ever to be
auctioned on sale the stone is almost 15
carats and Christie's estimates it could
sell for up to 45 million dollars
Sotheby's isn't concerned I think the
two diamonds actually are quite
different in shape in size in color I
don't really see them as competitive as
you might think I think it kind of
enhances the market to be honest with
you set the bees will soon find out if
America's darling Shirley Temple can
keep its record alive
you